so the daily wire has a story the dean
of students at an elite private school
in Chicago was allegedly recorded on
undercover video admitting to having a
group come into his classroom and pass
out sex toys during Pride week for
students to examine and to learn about
gay sex the video was captured by the
conservative action group project
Veritas post on social media Wednesday
evening
the video allegedly shows Joseph Bruno
dean of students at the Francis W Parker
school which cost tens of thousand
dollars to attend telling an undercover
activist for project Veritas about
activities that take place in his
classroom
uh we have the video which went uh
massively viral online uh thanks thanks
in part to the fact that Elon Musk has
allowed project Veritas to get back on
Twitter which there was no reason for
them to be kicked off Twitter the only
reason they were ever kicked off Twitter
is uh this is actually one of the most
outrageous examples of someone getting
banned from Twitter because the only
thing they ever did wrong was just
producing video that that that uh
embarrassed the left now they're back on
there they released this video so let's
let's watch
some of those go ahead
I had like our lgbtq plus Health Center
come in they were passing around butt
plugs and dildos to my students talking
about queer sex using blue versus using
spit meet Joe Bruno dean of students at
the prestigious Francis W Parker private
school in Chicago which happens to
charge forty thousand dollars per
student they're just like passing on
dildos butt plugs the kids are just
playing with them they're like how do
you how does this work how do we do like
how does this work that's a really like
a blue part of my job parents might be
stunned to learn that Bruno's version of
love and acceptance means handing out
sex toys to underage students
during Pride we do a pride week every
year and I had um
I had like our lgbtq plus Health Center
come in they were passing around butt
plugs and dildos to my students talking
about queer sex using blue versus using
spit who is this this is uh the lgbtq
plus Health Center came in to talk to my
high school students they're just like
passing our dildos butt plugs the kids
are just playing with them in the school
in a classroom wow yeah while I'm
sitting there and we had a drag queen
come in uh pass out cookies and brownies
and do photos and it's so amazing and
everybody's cool with that like they're
about plugs and their dildos nobody
complaints I mean if the parents found
out what they you know
queer sex this is the drag queen that
came in what's her name uh Alexis bevels
Alexis bevels and just hung out in my
classroom and was there girl hung out in
my office you have so much freedom and
so much
wiggle room
so much money I mean losing stuff these
are okay with that too oh yeah
they don't know okay
so much Freedom so much money
uh
this has got drag queen coming and just
just hanging out
hanging out in his office too he's uh I
wonder what they're up to
so he's he's got the cross-dressing
fetishes coming into the the classroom
um
and somehow that's not the most
outrageous thing that he's doing because
he is also having groups come in and
pass out sex toys to the children so
that they can according to him
play with the sex toys
uh during class
this is
a confession of uh sexual abuse
this is a confession of pedophilic
sexual abuse
by this monstrous
piece of garbage
and uh after this video came out how has
how how has this this school that people
are spending parents are spending tens
of thousand dollars to send their kids
to how did they respond well the first
thing they did was that they deleted
their Twitter account because that's
what you do when you're innocent right
the very first thing you do is you just
take everything down
uh very similar to I remember what
Vanderbilt did when we uh uh blew the
lid off of uh what was happening there
very first thing they did was they just
took down their entire website that
deals with gender transitions the gender
Clinic took it all down
um
yeah a real sign of Innocence there and
shortly thereafter we had this from
lives with Tick Tock had this update
Francis W Parker school in Chicago
Illinois where the dean of students
Joseph Bruno was caught on video uh
talking about giving students butt plugs
and dildos sent out this email to
parents saying that they stand in full
support of the dean
so this is the email that they sent out
we're ready to let you know that one of
our employees while at a conference last
week was targeted by a right-wing Fringe
group of individuals that seek to
undermine and manipulate diversity
Equity inclusion and belonging work in
schools
because when you're given out butt plugs
to kids to play with
that's just inclusion and belonging
this evening the group showed up outside
the school attempted to confront and
Ambush this employee with aggressive
questions a handful of students and
family members were present this
incident is very upsetting and we stand
in full support of our employee we have
put additional security measures in
place and we will notify the community
should there be any additional activity
from this group regarding the school of
uh regarding the school or our employee
we advise members of our community not
to engage with any organization that
fits this General profile
this is from Dan Frank the principal
don't engage with any organization
otherwise otherwise known as keep your
mouth shut
don't don't talk to anybody about this
um because this is uh this is just the
tip of the iceberg
can you imagine what else is going on
inside this school
I mean this is what this guy was willing
to admit to
now he truly didn't know he was being
recorded but he was sitting in a crowded
conference talking very openly about
this
so this is the stuff that we know about
um
they don't want us to find out about the
things we don't know about yet
and what do they do they they
immediately Circle the wagon around this
sexual abuser
and meanwhile we will be told that you
know the claim that there is sexual
grooming going on in the classroom is
some sort of it's all it's all a myth
it's a right-wing
fairy tale
but none of this is going to stop until
a guy like uh this this groomer this
pedophile
until someone like Joseph Bruno
you know until we have armed police
officers
busting into his home in the middle of
the night guns drawn
and frog marching him into a jail cell
okay in handcuffs until that is what
until that is the response none of this
stops
and I said that last night on Twitter
and of course someone did correct me and
say well no no we don't want the police
to uh bust into the house of middle
night we want to be in the middle of the
day
or maybe come into the school and start
dragging people out because we want this
to be visible to everybody we want
people to see it and that's true so I'll
take that correction yeah in fact not
middle of the night I prefer for it to
be in the middle of the day
and frog marched in front of jeering
crowds
heaping contempts
on this monstrous piece of crap
but our government and uh and you know
law enforcement agencies
they Reserve that kind of treatment for
pro-life activists
that's what happens to pro-life
activists in Philadelphia
they get pulled out of their homes at
gunpoint in the middle of night in
handcuffed and brought to jail
whereas men who admit to sexual abuse
this is sexual abuse if and there would
be no question about it I mean there's
no question about it here but
you take this out of the classroom
and you have this Joseph Bruno
um child groomer showing up to like a a
playground or a park or something
with a with a satchel full of dildos and
butt plugs and handing them out to the
children
everyone would agree that this guy is a
pedophile and needs to be charged with
sexual abuse and thrown in prison for
the rest of his life
but you take that and you put it into a
classroom and suddenly it's it's well
it's totally different so different
different rules entirely
but maybe I'm giving the left too much
credit I mean I I'm assuming that if
this guy was doing this with random kids
at a playground that they would that
even they would admit that it's
inappropriate at a minimum I'm not sure
if they would
remember as you've heard from me so many
times you talked about what is a woman
uh you get it you gotta know where this
stuff comes from you have to understand
uh where it all originates where it's
coming from
and this all this all goes back to
Alfred Kinsey and the effort to
sexualize children from birth and you
know he's yet another disciple of this
and the entire left they're all
Disciples of this uh of of that same
religion
and so they just don't they don't object
they have no problem with this
and I will do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]